[Music]
you better get it
yo what's going on we're back it's your
boy pranks season two it's bigger better
crazier pranks a lot of funny stuff is
about to happen I hope you're ready this
is the most expensive prop that Bel Air
has on its set
this would be a good prank to like
I'm not gonna actually drop it
assistant
[Music]
you do know you could have used a
flowering delivery service to save
thank you
[Music]
on camera
you know what I think Ali does he looks
really good today I love his outfit yeah
shot
another week
can I tell you people just keep telling
me how fantastic you hello
[Music]
I'm not even one yet
that was CGI that never happened
[Music]
you see that right there
you got that
no one has to get hurt
can I do that again
[Music]
like Ben Affleck
we are about to tape this iPhone to my
chest
and I'm gonna go around set pranking and
bothering people like I naturally do and
we're gonna capture the reactions in
smomo
[Music]
oh
you could have done better
costume Department I love the costume
Department they're amazing I feel like
they're about to get today
where are you thank you
you have a um
[Music]
all right
over here messing with me all right I'm
done I'm done okay
[Laughter]
[Music]